if nobody existed on earth you would do  everything the whole thing that drives  our society is affirmation people buy  bmws for acceptance people overextend  themselves on their first home and have  no cash and are trapped for a decade to  make mortgage payments for it to look  good what's great is when you don't hear  people think you're awesome it gives you  humility  but it also protects you from people  that think you suck and there's people  literally here not making content on  linkedin because they can't deal with  one random person saying they look bad  like literally you're gonna live your  life based on johnny pants 67